Trascrizione: Caterina Fava
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Chi, tra di noi, frequenta
in qualche modo la montagna?
Su le mani.
E chi, tra di noi, vive in montagna?
La montagna è bellissima:
è bellissima d'estate,
per camminarci al fresco;
bellissima d'inverno,
quando la neve copre tutto;
o adesso, d'autunno,
con i colori che esplodono.
Ma viverci?
Chi se la accolla,
di stare lassù al freddo
tra quattro gatti e con pochi servizi?
E chiaro: se ci sei nato,
il tuo cuore appartiene a questi luoghi.
Oppure magari sei un romantico,
un no global in fuga, magari mezzo matto;
ma altrimenti, chi te lo fa fare?
Perché mai tu, che ti consideri
una persona di mondo,
non sei nato in Montana
e non ci hai mai vissuto,
e hai anche un curriculum
che sarebbe un peccato buttare,
perché mai tu dovresti pensare
di vivere in montagna?
Un paio di mesi fa,
insieme ad una squadra
di ragazze e ragazzi
e un pensionato molto arzillo -
eravamo in otto -
abbiamo concluso
una lunga spedizione a piedi,
per le montagne di tutto lo stivale:
la spedizione "Và sentiero".
La nostra rotta è stata
il Sentiero Italia:
pensate, il trekking più lungo del mondo
in un paese così piccolo.
Per ottomila chilometri,
il "Sentiero Italia" si dipana
lungo tutte le montagne del Paese,
dalle Alpi agli Appennini,
dal Friuli Venezia Giulia
fino alla Sardegna.
Due anni fa, ci siamo messi in cammino
dal Golfo di Trieste:
e in 15 mesi, con alcune pause
anche dovute alla pandemia,
abbiamo attraversato
stagioni,  luoghi, situazioni,
ambienti completamente diversi,
dai canyon della Murgia ai Monti Pallidi
a qualche borgo sperduto dell'Aspromonte.
Ci siamo messi in cammino non per sport:
il nostro obiettivo
era quello di rilanciare
questo incredibile sentiero,
all'epoca semisconosciuto;
e attraverso questo viaggio lento,
cercare di raccontare
cosa sono oggi le "terre alte":
chi ci vive, che cosa sono,
come ci si sta, che aria si respira.
Da questa esperienza,
molto intensa,
mi sono portato dietro
alcune considerazioni.
E ce ne sono tre, in particolare,
che vorrei condividere qui con voi
che in qualche maniera ritengo utili
rispetto alla domanda iniziale:
perché mai tu dovresti pensare
di vivere in montagna?
In montagna, come nella vita,
avere una mappa, avere una bussola
è fondamentale per non perdersi.
Io credo però che, a volte,
anche perdersi possa essere una fortuna;
e come tale, occorre saperla cogliere.
"Perdersi" significa rimanere privi
dei riferimenti quotidiani
da cui dipendiamo.
E questo, a ben guardare,
ci dà modo di sfuggire
alla routine del quotidiano, all'inerzia,
all'effetto "catena di montaggio".
Perdersi significa rimanere
un po' soli, "spalle al muro",
alle prese con la domanda:
dove devo andare?
Dove voglio, andare?
E sei tu.
In quest'ottica,
perdersi può essere propedeutico
a cercare una direzione:
non una direzione qualsiasi, ma la tua.
Alcuni anni fa, nel 2016, avevo 29 anni.
Ed era uno di quei momenti esistenziali
in cui, per l'appunto, ti senti perso.
Immagino che a tanti di voi
sia successo lo stesso,
magari sta succedendo proprio adesso.
Per cercare di riordinare le idee,
o quantomeno ritardare questo momento,
andai a fare un viaggio a piedi
tra i monti della Corsica.
E là, camminando,
un giorno mi sono perso,
per rimanere in tema.
Ero su un altopiano,
è scesa una nebbia molto fitta,
ho smarrito la traccia sul terreno
e dopo un po' mi sono reso conto
che stavo girando in tondo.
E così, cercando di orientarmi,
a un certo punto vedo spuntare,
da questo muro di nebbia
tre fusti: tre ragazzoni alti,
biondi, tipicamente scandinavi,
anche loro con gli zaini.
E anche loro, come me,
si erano persi nella nebbia.
Allora abbiamo deciso
di cercare insieme il sentiero.
E così, chiacchierando,
a un certo punto uno di loro
si gira e mi fa:
"Ma tu che sei italiano,
lo conosci il Sentiero Italia?".
Il sentiero... che?
Io non lo avevo mai sentito nominare,
era la prima volta:
pensate che figuraccia.
Però quella figuraccia,
la domanda di quel ragazzo
sbucato a caso dalla nebbia,
sono stati in qualche maniera la scintilla
che ha portato me,
e tutti i miei compagni,
ad andarlo a scoprire,
questo Sentiero Italia,
a cercare una direzione.
In qualche maniera,
se quel giorno di qualche anno fa
non mi fossi perso
tra i monti della Corsica,
ma prima ancora un po' nella vita,
adesso non sarei qui a parlarvene.
Quindi, morale della favola:
se ti perdi, approfittane.
Approfittane per ritrovarti.
E già che ci sei,
magari fatti un giro in montagna
che chissà non porti fortuna.
A proposito di farsi un giro:
durante la pandemia, quanto ci è mancato
anche solo farci un giro nel giardino
dietro casa, nel parco?
Intrappolati nei nostri appartamentini,
all'improvviso ci siamo resi conto
di quale enorme potere
lo spazio circostante eserciti su di noi.
E quanto possa determinare
il nostro umore,
il nostro vivere quotidiano.
Abbiamo un po' scoperto
l'acqua calda, diciamocelo:
la questione è oggetto
di ricerca già da un po'.
Dagli anni cinquanta,
la psicologia ambientale indaga
proprio il rapporto tra l'ambiente esterno
e l'ambiente interno, quello psichico.
In particolare, c'è uno studio
di Rachel e Steven Kaplan
che approfondisce le caratteristiche
che un ambiente deve avere
per risultare stimolante, per attivarci.
Questo ambiente deve essere:
armonioso; coerente; mappabile;
deve essere ricco di variazioni, di forme,
di colori, di dimensioni;
ricco di spigoli e di angoli.
E così facendo, questo ambiente
risulterà complesso e misterioso.
Queste sono le parole dei Kaplan:
"complesso" e "misterioso".
Ora, in base a questi studi,
un ambiente del genere accende
il nostro istinto all'interazione;
e per questo motivo,
tali studi sono applicati
soprattutto alla progettazione
degli ambienti di lavoro,
per garantire una performance migliore.
Questo farebbe della montagna
un posto, uno scenario ideale
non soltanto per camminare
ma per lavorare, in teoria.
Ora, passando dalla teoria alla pratica
io finora la montagna
non l'ho vissuta stanzialmente.
Non di meno, l'ho vissuta a lungo,
camminando su e giù
lungo la schiena d'Italia.
In spedizione, vedete,
la nostra routine era suppergiù questa:
si camminava, chiaramente
dalle sei alle dieci ore,
20, 25, a volte 30 chilometri -
con buoni dislivelli,
esssendo in montagna -
e arrivati a fine tappa, belli sudati,
ci si dava una sciacquata;
e poi via, fino a sera.
Ognuno si trovava un angolino,
e si faceva smart working.
Ognuno tirava fuori il computer,
il telefono, l'hotspot -
e via col suo lavoro.
Chi a organizzare la logistica,
chi ad editare le foto, i video,
i social, le call, gli articoli,
la recensione della singola tappa,
i partner da gestire:
così, ogni giorno.
Percorrere e documentare
quasi ottomila chilometri
non è uno scherzo.
Pensate anche soltanto cosa significa
dormire ogni notte in un posto diverso,
giorno dopo giorno,
per mesi e mesi e mesi.
Può essere pesante,
può essere molto stressante:
il sonno arretrato; l'acido lattico;
tutti gli imprevisti da gestire;
gli infortuni;
l'assenza totale di spazi personali.
Insomma, possono esserci
dei crolli emotivi, anche importanti:
ne abbiamo avuti, eccome.
A volte non ci siamo anche parlati
per giorni, se non settimane.
D'altra parte, non abbiamo mai fatto
qualcosa di così estremo:
però, in qualche modo,
siamo sempre andati avanti fino alla fine.
Qualcosa ci ha stimolati a proseguire,
a marciare sotto il sole,
sotto la pioggia,
in qualche modo a portare avanti,
a termine il nostro lavoro
passando anche attraverso
una pandemia globale.
Penso che, chiaramente,
la nostra determinazione,
la nostra passione
hanno giocato un ruolo importante.
Però, stando agli studi di cui parlavamo.
anche l'ambiente circostante
ha giocato la sua parte.
E cioè la montagna,
la montagna che con le sue
caratteristiche spaziali
in qualche maniera ci ha riempito
di creatività, di vitalità,
ha possiamo dire "rabboccato"
la nostra energia.
Mi rendo conto che queste parole
possano suonare un po' romantiche:
la montagna, l'energia.
Però, pensateci: voi come vi sentite,
quando andate in montagna?
A proposito di andare in montagna,
c'è un oggetto che,
nell'immaginario collettivo,
un po' associamo all'andare in montagna.
Che cosa ci portiamo, quando si va
a camminare, sulle spalle?
Uno zaino: dobbiamo fare uno zaino.
Premetto: io ho una passione
compulsiva, per fare lo zaino.
Non so, posso stare ore
a comporlo, limarlo:
è come un bonsai, una sorta di rito Zen.
E in effetti, riflettendoci,
fare uno zaino è uno di quei
pochi momenti della nostra vita
in cui siamo costretti
a identificare l'essenziale,
per evidenti limiti di spazio, di peso,
che le nostre spalle possono sopportare.
E al contempo, fare uno zaino ci costringe
a identificare tutto ciò che è superfluo.
Ora, vedete: io penso che,
in qualche maniera,
vivere in montagna
sia un po' come fare uno zaino.
Da una parte, la montagna ci mette davanti
dei limiti ben precisi:
limiti di spazio, di persone,
di servizi, di lussi.
Vivere in montagna non ha
le comodità che offre la città:
non c'è il centro commerciale,
non c'è la movida.
Ad esempio,
quando nevica bisogna aspettare
che puliscano le strade,
perché non c'è la metro.
E al contempo, la montagna
ti obbliga a fare i conti
con il tuo essenziale.
Il tuo, essenziale.
E questo significa, in qualche maniera,
anche fare i conti con te stesso.
Con quelle domande un po' ingombranti,
tipo: che cosa conta?
Che cosa ti fa stare bene?
L'aria pulita, il centro commerciale
o che cosa?
Che cosa vuoi mettere nello zaino?
Perché sai, lo spazio è quello
e da lì non scappi.
Ora, a scanso di equivoci,
non esiste uno zaino giusto
e uno sbagliato:
ognuno ha le sue priorità, OK?
E queste domande, per fartele,
non è che devi per forza
andare in montagna:
puoi farti vedere dove ti pare,
anche adesso, qui.
Però, il più delle volte
un po' scappiamo, da queste domande.
Allora, la montagna
è semplicemente un facilitatore.
Ti costringe a farci i conti,
con queste domande:
ti mette davanti dei limiti.
E dall'altra parte, forse,
dà quello che per te è essenziale.
Questo perlomeno è quello
che è accaduto a me, in questo viaggio.
Quando abbiamo concluso la spedizione,
metaforicamente parlando
ho aperto il mio zaino
e l'ho trovato molto più leggero
di quello con cui ero partito.
Come se tanti presunti bisogni
siano come evaporati, superflui;
e dentro c'era solo quello
che per me è essenziale.
La consapevolezza di quello
che mi sta intorno,
di chi mi sta intorno;
il contatto con la natura, e il tempo.
Il tempo per me,
per fare le cose che amo fare.
Questo è quello a cui
io non posso rinunciare.
Di tutte queste parole,
che cosa ci rimane?
Diciamo che, guardando
alla domanda iniziale -
perché mai dovresti pensare
di vivere in montagna? -
più che altro ho seminato
delle ipotesi, dei dubbi.
Ti senti smarrito?
Allora forse potresti approfittarne.
Vuoi realizzare qualcosa
di nuovo, di sperimentale?
Forse una montagna può essere
il laboratorio ideale.
Forse.
Io vorrei soltanto augurare a tutti noi
di trovare la nostra direzione,
che la nostra direzione non rimanga
soltanto un disegno sulla mappa.
Però, per farlo, dobbiamo cercare,
uscire e cercare.
Ognuno deve fare i conti
con il suo zaino, e con le sue domande.
C'è una poesia di Brecht
che amo profondamente:
durante il viaggio, nei momenti
più complessi, più critici,
me la ripetevo,
un po' per per incoraggiarmi.
E termina con un verso molto potente:
"Non aspettarti nessuna
risposta oltre la tua".
Lo dice Brecht:
io non ho risposte per voi:
figuratevi, sto cercando
le mie, di risposte.
E mentre che cerco le risposte,
sto anche cercando casa
perché a furia di vagare, girovagare,
me ne è venuto un gran bisogno.
E anche una gran voglia di scoprire
se le sensazioni di cui vi ho parlato,
le sensazioni che provo lassù, camminando,
possano valere anche vivendoci, lassù.
E quindi, anzi: se qualcuno di voi
magari sa di una casa in Appennino,
be', mi faccia sapere.
D'accordo?
(Applausi)